[Musik]
sie haben wahrscheinlich schon vom block
10 gehört der rummel um den
block chain ist das rückgrat der krypto
währungen es hat viele aspekte unseres
lebens verändert
dies ist wahrscheinlich der ort von dem
man denkt er könnte dadurch verändert
werden
was wäre wenn ich ihnen sagen würde dass
er noch mehr kann
die blockzeiten revolution braut sich
zusammen nicht dort wo sie denken
in diesem zweiteiligen spezial treffe
ich die züchter lassen sie mich ihnen
unseren kühlraum zeigen hier züchten wir
unsere seegurken die lebensmittelhändler
ich möchte ihnen noch etwas
interessantes zeigen
und die stars also was man in der
physischen welt braucht ist eigentlich
das internet der dinge die welt der
lebensmittel dort blog chain verändern
stellen sie sich vor sie wissen genau
wie viele schritte dieses foul an ton im
laufe seines lebens getan hat
kann die technologie hinter der krypto
berlins wirklich helfen unsere
lebensmittel zu kennen
ich bekomme eine kostprobe von block
chain und warum das wichtig ist
[Musik]
die welt wird immer verrückter
und komplizierter
ich werde ihnen helfen den sinn zu
verstehen des teil ich bringe ihnen
besseren zugang spannendere geschichten
und tiefere einblicke ich werde ihnen
sagen warum es wichtig ist
also
ganz einfach es ist ein riesiges buch
das den austausch von gütern die geld
oder waren zwischen zwei oder mehreren
parteien aufzeichnet
stellen sie sich vor all diese daten
sind digital
und werden nicht nur auf einem sondern
auf vielen computern gespeichert
wie der name schon sagt werden
informationen über transaktionen
virtuellen behältern in sogenannten
blöcken gespeichert
diese blöcke sind digital
aneinandergekettet
diese verschlüsselten daten werden dann
allen computern im block chain netz wird
zur verfügung gestellt
so dass es fast unmöglich ist
aufgezeichnete daten zu ändern
[Musik]
dieser durch die datenspeicherung jetzt
nach herten meinung die welt verändern
wie genau das war ich von dr julien
horst autor von crypto währung einfach
erklärt also warum tun wir das damit die
leute nicht an dingen arbeiten die keine
geschäftlichen gründe haben julian ist
auch mitbegründer von the next einem
startup mit sitz in singapur so es ist
erst drei jahre alt letztes jahr war
tags unter den best finanzierten startup
der welt hier ist ein teil unseres teams
unser team ist unser kapital
investoren haben rund 80 millionen us
dollar in das erste museumsangebot von
terrex gesteckt und damit das
versprechen eingelöst crypto währung
investierbar zu machen und nx haben wir
vor etwa drei jahren angefangen und wir
fuhren von dieser sache namens crypto
währung bitcoin und so weiter und wir
dachten wie können wir all diese
virtuellen währung im echten leben
nutzen also haben wir mit einer
bankkarte angefangen die die leute mit
diesen crypto währungen verbinden können
dann können sie zu starbucks gehen und
ihre bitcoins tatsächlich für einen
kaffee ausgeben welche anderen
anwendungen gibt es was ein blog chain
macht ist anstatt informationen auf
einem firmenserver zu speichern kann ich
sie bei mir selbst speichern und ich
kann beweisen dass sich diese
informationen nicht manipuliert habe das
ist etwas was blog chains durch
kryptographie ermöglichen wie
unterscheidet sich das von anderen
datenbanken
das ist die zensur resistenz niemand
kann zensieren wie ein neuer blog
aussieht einer dieser informations
blöcke die integriert werden und niemand
kann die vergangenheit zensieren ich
kann also nicht einfach irgendetwas
entfernen oder hinzufügen ich kann
nichts blockieren diese resistenz ist
sehr mächtig weil sie verhindert dass
etwas manipuliert wird
die zweite sache ist transparenz jeder
kann die blöcke von heute bis ganz am
anfang sehen ich sehe wie der datenfluss
waren viele daten sind anonymisiert ich
kann also nicht sehen wer was gemacht
hat das ist in ordnung aber die
transparenz in diesem system ist extrem
hoch ich kann also buchstäblich sehen
wurde geld geschaffen wurde geld
vernichtet wie viel wurde tatsächlich
bewegt ich kann die teilnehmer nicht
sehen eine interessante anwendung ist
das finanzwesen denn ich kann speichern
wie viel geld ich besitze und jeder weiß
dass ich den betrag nicht verändert also
gestern hatte ich zehn dollar heute habe
ich plötzlich 10.000 dollar das könnte
ich mit blogs nicht machen es ist die
technologie also schon sehr
fortgeschritten aber noch nicht weit
verbreitet
im moment probieren wir nur herum wir
testen und sehen was möglich ist wir
sind noch in den 90er jahren des
internets also wirklich vor 20 jahren
es ist ein versuch ob das funktioniert
ob ein nutzer das tun würde es ist noch
in einem sehr frühen stadium
ich glaube es ist wirklich großartig für
unternehmen und regierungen
niemand weiß genau was in der zukunft
die entscheidenden anwendungen sein
werden
aber wir testen und wir befinden uns in
einem wirklich sehr frühen stadium
wenn ein land nicht in block 1
investiert wird es am ende den kürzeren
ziehen ich glaube eine regierung die
nicht im block chain investiert wird
verlieren das ist als würde man nicht
ins internet investieren dann hätte man
auf die letzten 20 jahre verpasst mit
block zählen gibt es viele wirklich
großartige anwendungen ich bin überzeugt
in den nächsten 20 jahren werden wir es
in allen lebensbereichen haben
er stellt sich heraus dass block chain
vielleicht schon früher auftaucht als
wir denken bei einem unserer liebsten
vergnügen dem essen
[Musik]
ich bin mir bei
einer veranstaltung zum thema
lebensmittel und gastgewerbe sie hat
nicht nur meine geschmacksnerven
gekitzelt sondern mir auch futter zum
nachdenken gegeben die herkunft von
lebensmitteln wie sollen wir wissen
woher unsere lebensmittel kommen und wie
können wir sicherstellen dass dieser
information nicht gefällt werden
[Musik]
die block chain technologie ist eine
tolle anwendung dafür das was wir auf
einem etikett sehen auch wirklich das
ist was wir essen oder trinken
wir glauben dass einer der besten
anwendungsbereiche für die blogs
technologie die lieferkette ist
nach dem vortrag habe ich mich mit dem
referenten max kant elia unterhalten
praxis mitbegründer von einem kind
die private blogs chains für
internationale unternehmen aufbauen
als jemand der guten wein und gutes
essen liebt ist er begeistert von der
potentiellen anwendung der branche auf
lebensmitteln
die blogs ein technologie wird also
immer mit grip bewährung in verbindung
gebracht ja warum dann
lebensmittelindustrie
glock chain ist eine wunderbare lösung
um vertrauen und transparenz in der
gesamten lieferkette zu schaffen
vom schweinemäster bis zu unserem tisch
chain ermöglicht es uns jede transaktion
transparent und für jeden verfügbar zu
machen
so kann das was zum beispiel auf dem
etikett steht in die kette eingegeben
werden und jeder teilnehmer in dieser
kette kann es sehen
wenn die technologie verfügbar
[Musik]
schwein kommen ausgeschlachtet wurde
sogar noch mehr als das es sagt ihnen
wie es vom bauernhof zum vertrieb kam
vom vertrieb zum spediteur und
es wird ihnen sogar sagen mit welchem
schiffes nach singapur heißt bevor es
ins restaurant kam indem sie es
vielleicht essen
und sie können die informationen nicht
manipulieren
die blogs chain technologie klingt wie
das wonach die singapurische café
unternehmerin per mail aktion gesucht
hat sie betreibt die kaffee akademie und
rösterei better barista
die benachteiligte frauen ausbildeten
einstellen dass ihre kaffeebohnen aus
einer nachhaltigen quelle kommen ist
sozial unternehmen sehr wichtig
darf ich fragen woher die bohnen stammen
wir wurden die wir heute verwenden sind
single origin kaffee aus myanmar
ist es wirklich so wichtig für ihre
kunden zu wissen woher
nun ich glaube die verbraucher machen
sich zunehmend gedanken über die
herkunft der lebensmittel für die
zutaten darüber wo unsere lebensmittel
herkommen ob sie ethisch und nachhaltig
erzeugt wurden
woher wissen sie das ihrem wohn ethisch
hergestellt
bei diesem café aus myanmar haben wir
die farmen besucht und mit den bauern
gesprochen zusammen mit unserem partner
der den kaffee dort verarbeiten
versuchen wir uns davon zu überzeugen
dass die bedingungen für die bauern gut
sind und stellen sicher dass das geld
auch bei ihnen ankommt das kostet
natürlich eine menge geld
ja es ist etwas das sich viele leute
nicht leisten können ich glaube mit
einer technologie wie der blog stellen
bei der man die daten nicht verändern
kann haben wir mehr möglichkeiten
transparent und authentisch mit diesen
informationen umzugehen
mit block sekunden
um zu beweisen dass sie in farmen fair
bezahlt hat könnten sie zum beispiel
einen kurzen dem etikett scan um zu
sehen ob mir ein fairtrade sieht gut aus
erstellt wurde
damit hat sie einen vorteil
deshalb trifft sie sich heute mit
einem block chain technologien drücker
wie chain mit sitz in shanghai hat sich
einen namen gemacht der aus block chains
für luxusmarken
[Musik]
im moment versuchen wir es für alle
zugänglicher zu machen also jeder ein
smartphone hat dann ist es einfach die
herkunft eines produkts zu überprüfen ja
man einen qr code auf der verpackung hat
braucht man nur ein smartphone um ihn zu
scannen dann wird er überprüft man kann
ein foto das produkt sehen so kann man
sich vergewissern dass er sich um das
richtige produkt handelt
und der aufregendste teil ist hier hier
kann man die zeit und das datum sehen
sobald etwas neues passiert und wer
daran beteiligt war das macht die
lieferkette also sehr sichtbar und man
kann nichts verändern ich kann also
nicht einfach reingehen und man kann
diese daten nicht manipulieren als
verbraucher kann ich darauf vertrauen
dass das was hier steht auch stimmt das
ist wirklich aus myanmar kommt das ist
der tag an dem es ihr lager verlassen
hat und der tag an dem es gerüstet wurde
die block 10 kann dazu beitragen dass
man nicht lügt und dass das was man in
seinem marketing an gibt auch wirklich
war so kann die blogs chain einem helfen
die von ihnen müsste ich wissen wie ihre
prozesse aussehen welche technologie ist
oder ob zum beispiel alles sehr manuelle
ja ziemlich im grunde genommen ist es so
wir arbeiten mit ineos café in myanmar
zusammen sie haben ein
verarbeitungszentrum im schönbuch land
und arbeiten mit ein paar hundert
kleinen bauern zusammen
während der erntezeit sammeln sie die
bohnen und bringen sie zur verarbeitungs
farm und dort macht genies alles fertig
dann geht es aufs schiff das schiff
kommt noch singapur wir holen es ab es
kommt in unser lager und
wenn wir dann so weit sind kommt es in
unsere lästerei da müssten wir den
kaffee und verpacken ihn in diese beutel
für den verbraucher
und dann geht s online an alle unsere
einzelhandelsstandorte
das ist also sozusagen die kette dass
man also in der physischen welt braucht
ist ein das internet der dinge zum
beispiel einen qr-code um eine kurze
kette zu veranschaulichen könnte meinen
kollegen vielleicht zu ihrem
einzelhandelsgeschäft gehen lassen und
dann bringen wir ihnen hier her und
lassen ihn wieder ein scan um zu zeigen
dass der standort an zwei verschiedenen
orten erkannt
also machen wir ihnen auf die verpackung
motto ja wir machen einen qr-code auf
die packung bringen sie in den laden und
lassen sie es gerne so dass die zeit und
der ort in der block chain angezeigt
werden
[Musik]
wie sie also sehen können ist der kaffee
am plaza singapurer angekommen er wurde
zum grünen geöffnet hier ist eine zeit
dazu und auch ein ort singapur central
können wir genauer werden weil
eigentlich ist plaza singapur ja eine
bestimmte orte also zur demo zwecken
zeigen wir singapur ost oder singapur
zentrum
natürlich wenn wir zusammenarbeiten
können wir das für sie machen mit
genaueren koordinaten wo der scan
gemacht wurde das wäre viel nützlicher
kamera block jay noch mehr potenzial als
nur die rückverfolgbarkeit
wenn eine kette vom bahnhof diesem tisch
geschaffen wurde kann theoretisch auch
ein mechanismus für die bezahlung einer
tasse kaffee kentrup so werbung
geschaffen werden und aufgrund der
transparenz die eine blockt anbietet
kann ich als verbraucher tatsächlich
verfolgen
wenn ich nicht nur den barista trinker
geblieben die züchter direkt
unterstützen will kann ich das tun
[Musik]
die verwendung von block jain für die
rückverfolgung von lebensmitteln ist den
sänger bono relativ neu
aber ein land es war schon sehr weit
vorn
[Musik]
laut der us amerikanischen handelskammer
war china 2016 für 86 prozent der
weltweit gefälschten waren
verantwortlich
das sind rund 400 milliarden us dollar
kein wunder dass man in china
fälschungen original nicht unterscheiden
kann aber hier geht das problem über
markenartikel hinaus
und betrifft auch die lebensmittel die
hessen
dort fand
das größere problem bei gefälschten
lebensmitteln ist natürlich die
lebensmittelsicherheit
von melamin im milchpulver bis hin zum
ausgeben von rotem fleisch als
hammelfleisch an die letzten zehn jahren
hat china eine reihe von
lebensmittelskandalen erlebt
[Musik]
seit dem milchpulverskandal 2008 ist
china immer noch ein heißes pflaster für
kontaminierte und gefälschte
lebensmittel
[Musik]
aus dem jahr 2017 ergab dass vier von
zehn chinesen lebensmittelsicherheit als
sehr großes problem sehen
hier besteht also ein riesiger bedarf an
informationen über die herkunft von
lebensmitteln
denn es geht um leben oder tod
darauf reagieren jetzt einige
lebensmittel riesen
einer von ihnen ist die dot com
der einzelhändler will mit block seien
so viele waren wie möglich bis zum
bauernhof verfolgen
und ich kann all diese informationen
bequem von meinem hotelzimmer aus
abrufen
eine einfache suche auf den beliebten
chinesischen einzelhandels plattform
zeigt mir die vielfalt der produkte
reicht von verpackten lebensmitteln mit
pulver
[Musik]
bis hin zu tierprodukten visier
jamie ist der größte rivale von alibaba
es ist das zweitgrößte e commerce
unternehmen in china
2012 mit einem online einkauf von
lebensmitteln
sechs jahre später eröffnete es sein
ersten stationären laden hier im norden
pekings distrikt
flagship supermarkt von jenny ist 4000
quadratmeter groß viele seiner produkte
werden über die blogs chain verfolgt
sehen sie hier ist ein qr code auf der
packung
ich kann dies ebenfalls öffnen und mit
der scan funktion den qr code auf der
packung scannen
er zeigt mir woher es kommt eine
produktionsfirma die farben
informationen
das macht die lieferkette von dem gemüse
sichtbarer
[Musik]
ich möchte ihnen noch etwas
interessantes zeigen
schauen sie hier ist ein qr code auf dem
fisch
wenn ich ihn kenne komme ich auf die
seite mit den ganzen infos
sie wissen genau woher der fisch kommt
und zu welchem datum wann er gefischt
und wann er getestet wurde
der verband der lebensmittel hersteller
schätzt dass ein einziger vorfall von
lebensmittel betrug das unternehmen zwei
bis 15 prozent seines jährlichen
umsatzes kosten kann
für ein riesiges unternehmen wie adidas
im letzten jahr insgesamt 55 7
milliarden us dollar umsatz gemacht hat
könnte das ein verlust von über 1,1
milliarden dollar bedeuten
der kampf gegen lebensmittel betrug ist
also ernst
sie öffnen ihre blog chain sogar für
ihre lieferanten und andere unternehmen
damit auch sie ein sicheres und
transparentes lieferkettenmanagement
management
der ehemalige informatik professor dr
waging ist entwickelt diese technologie
als einer der meist zitierten autoren
auf diesem feld verfügt über mehr als 25
jahre akademische erfahrung
[Applaus]
wenn wir lieferkette sagen wissen wir
was das ist aber viele leute tun sich
schwerer als typische kunden tun sich
schwer eine lieferkette wirklich zu
begreifen das ist ein sehr trockenes
konzept
man kann es nicht
aber durch diesen rückverfolgung dienst
können die leute jetzt wirklich die
vorteile der block chain nutzen und die
vielen informationen erhalten die
während des gesamten prozesses gesammelt
werden
war das nicht möglich bevor es die blogs
and technologie
den vorteil der block chain ist dass man
informationen von mehreren parteien
erhalten kann und
diese parteien kennen sich vielleicht
gar nicht treffen sich nicht und
vertrauen sich vielleicht nicht einmal
und die blogs macht es möglich eine
solche zusammenarbeit auf effektive und
effiziente weise zu erleichtern
stellen sie sich vor sie wüssten genau
wann diese pilze geerntet worden
oder ob für dieses gemüse pestizide
verwendet worden
wie viele schritte dieses freiland huhn
im laufe seines lebens zurückgelegt hat
[Musik]
in china ist das bereits realität
heute verfolgt die 14.000 produkte von
500 marken in der branche
[Musik]
und eines der ersten nutztiere das in
der box enthalten ist
[Musik]
ich bin in der provinz liaoning im
wasser um mich herum sie millionen von
see
gegangen das können sie selbst sehen
was ich meine ist sie können sich die
überwachungsvideos der aquakultur fahren
hier auf der chinesischen e commerce
website die dot com ansehen wieder traum
auf der webseite wechselt das was sie
sehen zufällig zwischen den fast 100
kameras
[Musik]
liefert company hat beschlossen die
aufnahmen seinem blog chain hochzuladen
die man dann auf der webseite und der
mobilen anwendung von check.com sehen
kann sie möchten dass die verbraucher
die herkunft und echtheit ihrer sie
gucken selbst überprüfen
[Musik]
warum sollte ein unternehmen so viel
aufwand betreiben um die herkunft
nachzuweisen ich habe mich darüber
gewundert bis ich feststellte dass es
einen enormen preisunterschied zwischen
sekunden an verschiedenen orten geerntet
wurden
nehmen sie zb dieser sieg sie sehen
gleich aus aber ich finde schnell heraus
dass die eine 600 dollar mehr kostet als
die andere
wir sind hier in einem raum lagerungen
zubereitung von seegurken gedacht ist es
ist eine spezialität dieses restaurants
dass seine fast 90-jährigen geschichte
in peking hat und hier ist auch der
chefkoch antwort er schon seit 40 jahren
hier arbeitet meister an dass zu viele
arten von seegurken gibt
ich würde sie gerne testen die sechs
gruppen hatten hier kosten zwischen 800
und 5000 yuan
jeder hat einen anderen preis ich möchte
dass sie nach preis sortieren
ok ich werde mal raten durch mein
begrenzt des wissen übersee gruppen weiß
ich je mehr starten sie haben desto
teurer sind sie
lassen nämlich versuchen zu erraten
welches die billigste ist okay denn also
ich nehme die mit den wenigsten stacheln
diese hier hat ziemlich kurze starren
aber sie sieht ein bisschen
verschrumpelt oder ein bisschen fertig
aus
ich würde sagen dass das die billigste
ist es ist diese seegurke hat die
meisten stacheln und die länge der
staffeln ist auch ziemlich lang
musste von allen sechs arten die hier
also schätze ich das ist die teuerste
und
dadurch recht sie haben recht das ist
die billigste und das ist die teuerste
also hatte ich recht ja die kostet
ungefähr 1000 hier an
das ist die teuerste
sie kommt aus japan und kanto region sie
kostet etwa 5000 yuan pro 600 gramm sie
sind also ein experte für sekunden aber
wie sieht es mit den normalen chinesen
aus die auf dem markt gehen und sie
gurken kaufen wissen die genau so viel
wie sie
der mann auf der straße weiß vielleicht
nicht wirklich wie man sehr guten ernte
chinas wirtschaft hat sich erst in den
letzten dreißig bis vierzig jahren
geöffnet
der lebensstandard der einfachen leute
ist erst in den letzten jahrzehnten
gestiegen früher hätten sich die meisten
leute seegurken nicht leisten können
ich habe gelernt dass hochwertigen
seegurken aus leonding ziemlich viel
geld kosten weil die gewässer in denen
sie aufwachsen kälter sind
wenn es um betrug geht related desy
campus wer in den verbrauchern meistens
gurten minderer qualität zu höheren
preisen verkauft
jemand stirbt aber die menschen sind
verständlicherweise verärgert dass sie
nicht die qualität bekommen die ihnen
versprochen wurde
[Musik]
die new york stellt seine sie gucken auf
die blogs um den kunden zu versichern
dass die gekauften seegurken jeden cent
wert
[Musik]
ich treffe die schranken und ziehen
europe ihre aufgabe ist es
sicherzustellen dass jede seegurke die
produziert wird die hohen standards
erfüllt die die kunden erwarten
wollen sie den kunden zeigen
die daten die wir unseren kunden geben
stamm von dieser tat fähig sie zeigen
wie das produkt verarbeitet wird wann
und unter welchen bedingungen es
hergestellt wird
anhand dieser informationen können
unsere kunden im detail nachvollziehen
wie und wann das produkt verarbeitet
wurde und wieder aufzucht prozess
wir hoffen auf diese weise das vertrauen
unserer kunden zu gewinnen
durch die kette von daten gibt es keine
verwirrung mehr über die herkunft
zeige ihnen jetzt unseren kühlraum na ja
und jetzt richten wir unsere
sich nach transparenten prozess ich
herausfinde dass die daten manuell
eingegeben
also bleibt die gefahr menschlicher
fehler warum sollte ich also abgesehen
von den überwachungsbehörden und
informationen vertrauen
ich wende mich anziehen long blog zehn
anbieter die um antworten zu bekommen
kann ich bestimmte informationen
festlegen und auf die ketten setzten
sehr gute frage sie haben einen guten
blick in das geschäft in der tat ist das
eine große chance für die technologie
zum beispiel können wir die ios geräte
verwenden um einige der informationen zu
sammeln wie die temperatur die umwelt
variablen und diese informationen dann
direkt in die block chain einspeisen
ich verstehe es muss also ein
maschineller prozess sein keine
menschliche ein menschlicher man braucht
also eine ganze infrastruktur damit das
ganze tracking system auf der block 10
realisiert werden kann
[Musik]
das internet der dinge das
bezieht sich auf ein netzwerk von
geräten es ist nicht nur eines der
großen schlagworte in der geschäftswelt
in der sonnen verändert auch unseren
alltag
schon heute können sie für wenig geld
ihr smartphone so einrichten dass es mit
allen elektrischen geräten in ihrem haus
verbunden ist
um das licht zu steuern ihre
lieblingsmusik zu spielen hier ist ein
spotify oder
[Musik]
luft zu können damit es sich gut anfühlt
wenn man nach hause kommt
der haken an der sache ist es kostet
nicht viel das eigene haus intelligenter
zu machen bei kleinen bis mittleren
unternehmen dürfte das mehrere
zehntausend euro kosten
das klingt nach einem kostspieligen
unterfangen und müsste der verbraucher
einen teil der kosten übernehmen die
kosten für die einrichtungen der ersten
block chain anwendungen sind meistens
hoch
aber solange man den anwendungsbereich
und umfang erweitert gleichen sich die
kosten am ende aus
also kostet es am ende wenig das ist
auch der grund warum in den nächsten
fünf jahren wenn die blogs chain
technologie zum industriestandard wird
die kosten niedriger sein werden
also jetzt weiß ich dass die blog chain
zwar verschlüsselt gibt aber nur so
zuverlässig ist in die daten aus denen
sie gespeist wird
aber selbst wenn die daten stimmen
was ist wenn das produkt ist konnte die
url verweist immer noch auf dem selben
link in der block chain aber das produkt
ist nicht mehr dasselbe
bitcoin mag die schlagzeilen beherrschen
aber die technologie hinter der krippe
währung kann mehr
in china wird die block chain zur
rückverfolgung von lebensmitteln
eingesetzt
das heißt dass man wichtige
informationen über produkte abrufen kann
ihn zwar hiermit
ein qr-code also ein quick response code
is kleine brücke er verbindet das
produkt in der physischen welt mit
information in der digitalen welt
diese muss da können nur von maschinen
gelesen werden wenn man also einen
qr-code scannt übersetzen die maschinen
dass informationen die wir lesen können
es gibt auch nfc die
nahfeldkommunikation
nfc gehört zu einer technologie namens
rfid
radiofrequenz-identifikation rfid
wird jeder gegenstand mit funkwellen
eindeutig identifiziert bei nfc werden
die daten sicherer oder eine höhere
frequenz übertragen wenn sie zwar mit
einem chip
[Musik]
das los
angeles eines der wenigen unternehmen
der branche dass seine eigenen sensoren
entwickelt und herstellt
hier stellen wir unsere chips her es
gibt verschiedene arten
hier haben wir qr-codes
man kann ihnen auf der verpackung
anbringen wenn man sie öffnet wird die
antenne zerstört das hier ist eine neue
generation
er enthält sowohl audi als auch nfc
das ist sehr einfach sehr unternehmens
freundlich und areva die ist im lager
sehr nützlich man kann es aus großer
entfernung scannen und die produkte in
stapeln erfassen aber
gleichzeitig braucht darf die ein
spezielles lesegerät so dass es für den
endverbraucher nicht sehr einfach zu
benutzen ist wenn es also in einem
geschäft ankommt kann man nur nfc
benutzen
endverbraucher können ein nfc einfach
mit ihrem handy scannen
es gibt unterschiedliche bedürfnisse für
die lager und die verbraucher
eine fusion
[Musik]
welche möglichkeiten gibt es auf einen
block chain zuzugreifen
es spielt keine rolle ob das ein qr-code
ein rfid oder ein nfc chip ist
es ist nur eine möglichkeit das produkt
zu kennzeichnen
wir entwickeln verschiedene methoden die
auf derart und auch auf dem wert des
produkts basieren wenn man das produkt
mit einem chip versieht sind die kosten
natürlich höher als bei einem qr-code
wir arbeiten mit einigen weinkellereien
und weinproduzenten zusammen sie haben
viele hochwertige weine die über 1000
türen oder so kosten
[Musik]
ist also der wein und hier ist der nfc
chip hier sehen sie wie er angebracht
wird sie nehmen den nfc-chip um ihn zu
scannen
verifiziert die app die identität dieser
flasche sobald das passiert ist können
sie sehen das ist eine eindeutige id und
wenn sie mehr informationen wollen dann
haben sie die produktgeschichte die
beschreibung und in der realen welt
haben sie auch logistische informationen
welche technologie wird der schlüssel
zum blog geschenkt in der zukunft sein
die antwort ist nicht offensichtlich
bedenken sie folgendes konto bis
dahin 2007 rotwein des berühmten mammuts
wenn er das ist was er zu sein vorgibt
kostet er stolze 900 dollar
wenn er es nicht ist
beruhigt sie sind wahrscheinlich nicht
allein denn es ist einer der am meisten
gefälschten weine in china man würde
erwarten dass der vertreiber solch
seltener weine die staatliche direct.de
auf die nfc technologie setzt
die sichere und anpassbarer ist
aber das ist nicht der fall
also was sehen wir hier
man kann leicht herausfinden wann der
wein kommt und von welchem wein gut also
es gibt
ja das weingut wurde 1882 gegründet das
ist ein sehr traditioneller
familienbetrieb
[Musik]
ein zentrum hat mehr als 200 mitglieder
sie sind alle an einem rückverfolgung
system interessiert die versuchen den
gesamten chinesischen markt zu
vermitteln dass man wein auf viel
sicherere weise genießen kann aber wenn
wir über die kosten sprechen sagen sie
okay das ist zu viel für uns über drei
jahren haben wir die verbände kostete
fast einen yuan pro chip aber jetzt
nehmen wir kuerten kosten vielleicht 10
wir wollen dass mehr unternehmen sich
uns anschließen müssen wir die kosten
für die tags oder chips senken der park
wurde chips langfristig gleichen sich
die kosten also aus und der eigentliche
gewinn ist die sicherheit die sie ihren
kunden geben können oder
darauf stoßen wir an ok sollten sie das
glas geben oder
[Musik]
qr-codes kosten weniger unternehmen
bevorzugen sie um auf informationen in
ihrem blog chains zuzugreifen mit haken
ist was ist wenn ich das mache ich
mache eine kopie des qr codes
und
oder dass hier
die url verweist immer noch auf
denselben linken der block c aber das
produkt wurde verändert
[Musik]
in china spielt die block 1 bereits eine
große rolle bei der sicherung der
lebensmittel
viele lebensmittel hanko er kurz tvi
darüber informieren woher sie kommen
aber mir ist klar dass qr-codes alles
andere als narrensicher sind wenn ich
wollte endlich den inhalt leicht
manipulieren die url verweist immer noch
auf den selben link in der block c aber
das produkt wurde verändert
um dies zu verhindern hat der teck und
tommy haas berlinski eine intelligente
verpackungslösung entwickelt ja es ist
mitbegründer von we may im block chain
startup das baby nahrung in china
importiert und vertreibt
wenn man sich die branche anguckt gibt
es ziemlich viele behauptungen und einen
hype um geblockt sie würde das problem
der fälschungen lösen aber das ist
einfach nicht der fall denn selbst wenn
man den gefälschten qr-code scannt
erhält man das ergebnis dieses
datensatzes der in der block schein
existiert
und was noch schlimmer ist als das
produkt nicht zu schützen ist dass es
ihnen ein gefühl der sicherheit gibt
dass das produkt sich mit der block
chain zu authentifizieren scheint also
muss es war sein und das ist der grund
warum die blockzeiten im moment das
problem der fälschungen nicht alleine
lösen kann man braucht dafür zusätzlich
etwas und das tun wir und was ist dieses
extreme die blogs chain wirklich sicher
zu machen
das ist im wesentlichen ein physischer
schutz des produkts man muss
sicherstellen dass es diese 11
korrespondenz zwischen block chain und
einem physischen objekt gibt etwas das
man nicht in einer unendlichen anzahl
von kopien reproduzieren kann
teure mode was wir uns ausgedacht haben
das ist eine der älteren generationen
des etiketts aber es funktioniert immer
noch gleich sie sehen hier wir schützen
das produkt nicht nur auf der blog chain
also digital sondern auch physisch
der anspruch den wir erheben und das
versprechen dass wir dem verbraucher
geben ist das wenn dieses ding
authentisch ist heißt das dass die
verpackung nicht manipuliert wurde
ein elektronisches gerät unter dem leben
im grunde ist das ein label richtig es
basiert auf der nfc technologie und was
sie hier in dem schalk reich sehen ist
im wesentlichen eine antenne die mit
einem nfc-chip verbunden ist schauen sie
dieses zifferblatt füllt sich mit den
prozentsätzen das ist wenn die daten mit
der block chain ausgetauscht werden alle
informationen wurden mit einer blog
schon überprüft das ist also was der
verbraucher sieht richtig das sind alle
standard informationen die logistische
nachverfolgung infos über das produkt
und so weiter
was ist das sein die scan standorte
das ist eigentlich unser testmuster
also immer wenn wir es auf eine reise
zum vorzeigen mitgenommen haben wurde es
in der block 10 registriert
werden auch die daten auf einen
zusätzlichen blog gelegt und jedesmal
hinzugefügt wenn jemand den chips gern
zu dem datensatz der genau zu diesem
produkt gehört ja ich verstehe warum ist
logwin also der richtige weg für sie
sehen sie wir sind nicht die ersten die
versuchen das problem mit den
fälschungen in china zu lösen
die verbraucher haben schon jeden
glauben an solche behauptungen verloren
sie sagen mir dass sie nur echte sachen
verkaufen aber warum sollte ich ihnen
glauben es gibt zehn andere unternehmen
die das gleiche tun und sie scheitern
unweigerlich
wenn wir blog chain benutzen müssen sie
nicht uns vertrauen sondern der
technologie
solange sie also verstehen wie die
technologie funktioniert müssen wir
nicht überzeugend seien
sie authentifiziert uns also als
unternehmen
[Musik]
babys sind gestorben nachdem sie mit
melamin verseuchte milch getrunken haben
300.000 andere wurden krank verseuchte
chinesischem in china skandal um
babymilchpulver auf der ganzen welt
wächst die sorge um die sicherheit
chinesischer milchprodukte
der milchpulver skandal von 2008 bei dem
sechs babys starben und 300.000 krank
wurden ist erfolgt die chinesen bis
heute der vertrauenskrise verschärfte
sich als ende 2015 ein weiterer skandal
um gefälschte milch in shanghai
aufgedeckt wurde
das soll verdächtige wurden beschuldigt
billiges milchpulver als markenprodukt
ausgegeben zu haben über 12.000 dosen
mit marken milchprodukten waren
betroffen
ich bin ein vater
wichtig zu wissen ob man eigentlich
pulver gepanscht wurde
ich möchte jahres lassen
ich treffe mich mit seinem
verkaufsleiterin einem lagen des biene
produkte verkauft was ist wenn ich den
aufkleber ganz vorsichtig abziehe sodass
der stromkreis nicht unterbrochen wird
versuchen sie es versuchen sie es ruhig
ok schwer zu versuchen ich glaube das
schaffen sie nicht
ja klar das ist unser physischer schutz
um jede art von wiederverwendung oder
recycling dieser produkte zu verhindern
aber noch etwas sie brauchen ihr handy
um es zu verfolgen wenn sie also das
etikett zerrissen oder kaputt gemacht
haben können sie nichts mehr scannen
weil der kreislauf unterbrochen ist die
antenne ist kaputt wenn die antenne
kaputt ist ist die verbindung zum
nfc-chip komplett unterbrochen
[Musik]
ich war ermutigt hat sich china verließ
nicht durch den stand der technologie
die noch einen langen weg vor sich hat
bevor sie zum mainstream wird sondern
von den talentierten männern und frauen
die sich dem ziel verschrieben haben
eine bessere welt zu schaffen eine welt
in der wir unseren lebensmitteln
vertrauen können und genau deshalb ist
es so wichtig
[Musik]